so a lot of people are going to be
listening to this and say but there
you're not offering any net any social
safety net for the people that need it
the most and at the same time if you're
saying that the minimum wage doesn't
work even for all the philosophical
reasons that you lay it out they're
gonna say but no matter what there's a
certain amount of people that need help
I generally basically believe that which
is why I haven't fully gone libertarian
so what's the response so I agree
there's certain number of people I think
it's very small by the way who need help
because I think capitalism in all of
history
anyway it's tried creates more jobs than
there are people so anybody who is able
can work and work at a decent living
where they can live their life without a
lot of help but look emergencies happen
bad stuff happens to people and some
people truly cannot survive right
they've got they've got problems whether
whether the brain is not developed
enough for the body is not developed
into something they need to be taking
care of right so I believe in a safety
net I just don't believe that government
should provide it I don't believe I
should be cost to help them write you
and help them I want to help them we can
get together start a foundation so
charity is the safety net charity was
the safety net the 19th century but not
only charity you know that in the 19th
century they sold insurance against
poverty they were mutual aid societies
we would all get together and buy
insurance in a sense insuring all of us
you know a mutual type of insurance deal
in order for poverty or for if your
house burned down or kind of just
generally bad stuff happening in life um
you could in a in a true flea market and
health care for example you could buy an
insurance policy maybe even for life on
a baby that hasn't been born yet I mean
the possibilities once you free up the
economy from regulations and controls if
you actually let people make decisions
based on their own interest unbelievable
such I don't believe anybody's gonna be
dying in the streets I don't believe
anybody
I believe the opposite I think fewer
people will die from poverty few people
will be heard from Hardy I think people
would be much richer much better off and
that they've safety net that exists will
be much more effective and driven
primarily towards those people who for
no fault of their own in the situation
some people deserve
fate that they get if you're a wife
beating drunk capitalism is not good for
you yeah yeah but I'm all for that I
believe in justice I believe in fairness
fairness is not equality fairness means
getting what you deserve and white being
drunks deserve bad stuff happening to
them so it's so interesting to me how it
really sounds like a branding issue
because people think of capital there's
this idea now and I think it has a lot
to do with crony capitalism and the way
our politicians have allowed you know
corporations to basically steal from
America and you know hide money else in
high taxes but we of course subject to
cronyism right and the only solution to
cronyism is to shrink government power
so the government doesn't get involved
in business a business doesn't have any
center of the lobby it so so that's
basically Atlas Shrugged right there
that was the you just gave me the one
cent the smaller the government the less
cronyism there's I mean there's a famous
story about Microsoft in 1994 they were
brought in front of Congress and Orrin
Hatch who was then a young senator from
Utah lamb blasted them for not lobbying
for not having a presence in Washington
DC for not doing all the things that
corporate America is expected to do and
Microsoft walked away and said look you
leave us alone we'll leave you alone
we're not interested yeah right and of
course six months later the Justice one
comes knocking it goes after Microsoft
forgiving a product away for free
Internet Explorer right destroys the
company from my perspective right
today Microsoft spends tens of millions
of dollars a year they have a beautiful
building in Washington DC about equal
distance from the capital in the White
House mm-hmm this is how it happens the
politicians come and they say give us a
handout or when we write the regulations
we're gonna screw you Wow I really want
to get into that percent because I
remember that happening 1994 I was I
think a senior in high school I remember
that so Internet Explorer was just the
int it was the Internet browser that was
built into Windows yes basically the
government said you have a monopoly on
this right yes but of course Netscape
invented web browsing right it was
charging I think was 50 or 70 bucks a
pop and here was being being bundled
with the operating system and Netscape
was saying wait a minute we can't
compete against a fleet product you're
dumping in the odds and this is
antitrust laws in it you know just quick
the antitrust laws and this is absurdity
of antitrust laws if you sell a product
really really cheap then you're
violating antitrust laws because you're
dumping if you sell a product much more
expensive than your competitors you must
have a monopoly so you're in violation
of antitrust laws and if you sell your
product at the same price as your
competitors you're colluding yeah
collusion because how would you sell it
all at the same price so that's like the
the cellphone companies they because
everybody's within five bucks antitrust
is a law that is meaningless
it is completely at the discretion of
the regulator when to apply it and win
lot and that's what authoritarians
always love they love laws that are not
clear that are not objective so they can
choose you didn't pay me this month so
I'm going to go after you right you're
not lobbying so I'm going to have to you
Google has loved us like Google and
Netflix and these guys they spent huge
amounts of lobbying Democrats
Republicans they spread it all around
it's interesting that Google has no
antitrust problems Apple does because
Apple does it has lobbied very little
okay Microsoft did because it all be
zero so this is the game that's being
played and it's a game that is
determined by the politicians they're
the ones with the guns they're the ones
forcing this upon businessman right so
is there a risk there though that if you
remove all of that stuff that the
companies eventually will become more
powerful than the government now I
suppose you wouldn't view that as a risk
per se but that Apple at this point the
Apple has more money than the government
right Apple great apples in the back you
know look this is the difference yeah
and it's a fundamental confusion this is
what you said a lot of this is about
woods
it's about wood yes but the deeper
philosophical meaning of woods there's
such a thing as economic pound is such a
thing as political power political power
is about coercion
it's about guns it's about force
economic power is about voluntary
transactions I have no problem
companies gaining more and more and more
economic power they can only have that
power as long as I voluntarily choose to
trade with them right I can choose to
buy a Samsung tomorrow I can choose to
boycott Apple for a variety of reasons
if I want to tomorrow there are other
choices right always a choices but there
is the risk that they could just buy
every other company and eventually have
a happen it never happened so the
better mousetrap will always come along
además took the classical example of
this is is rockefeller right had 90 plus
percent of all oil refining in the in in
nineteen in the 1870s right so monopoly
so what were we taught an econ 101
prices go up quality goes down never
happen prices went down every single
yeah I anybody to look at the data go
down every quality goes down over here
because Rockefeller understood that if
he raised prices
competition would come about and
competition will often come about from
products you would never expect so for
example in the 1870s Rockefellers oil
was being used for kerosene the lightest
who competed him out of that business
I guess the yeah what your cracker what
central planner would have sat back in
1870 says yeah this guy in that lab he's
gonna compete nobody would have imagined
that that's the beauty of real freedom a
real capitalism today of course Edison
would have never been allowed to have
the lab because he violated every code
in the book I'm sure he didn't wait
goggles when he's experiment there's no
way they'd allow that oh yeah so in 19th
century had we had relative freedom and
the consequence was the greatest pace of
innovation in human history the biggest
innovative leaps in human history I mean
really today we get another app and we
get all excited electricity was invented
right right lighting think of all the
stuff that comes from electricity and
then think of the trains automobiles
airplanes I mean the innovation tonight
in the nineteen century part of the
twentieth century a massive today the
little incremental so is that possible
that just sort of the arc of humanity
has changed where those those things
know so you think its boundless it
really is I think it's boundless and I
think what's constraining today is our
educational system which is pathetic
particularly in science and math and and
the things we teach kids to think and I
think it's it's political I think when
you regulate people when everything you
do is by permission mm-hmm people don't
take risks people don't challenge
themselves and this is what I meant by
the enemy of the mind is the gun if I
put a gun to your back of your neck
can say these things you cannot do it
shuts down whole parts of the mind and
this is exactly what the Enlightenment
was fighting against this is the whole
idea of free speech and free inquiry was
the ideas you can't shut down the human
mind you can't shut it down in science
you can't shut it down in philosophy or
/ religion you can't select you can't
shut it down when it comes to business
because what you do when you do that is
you destroy whole areas of inquiry and
so those in question will be wrong I
mean some experiments you don't blow up
in your face right but you got it you
got it fail in order to be successful
when we bail people out when we don't
allow restructurings when we don't allow
the dynamism that exists we suffer the
reason we have so much innovation in
Silicon Valley is because that is the
least regulated industry in our economy
the reason Wall Street keeps collapsing
is because it is the most regulated
industry in our econ so ok so Wall
Street is regulated and we bail them out
and when they're too big to fail we make
them bigger sure so I get all that so
what would the alternative been if we
had just actually let them all fail
I mean people basically say Obama's
saying it's a false alternative right
alternative is 80% regulation or 90% of
regulation no the alternative is zero
right the alternative is unwind the
system the alternative is to get rid of
them you know pages and pages and book
loads of regulations over the financial
industry free them up completely that
will probably lead to a completely
different-looking banking system than
what we have today but also make it
clear we're not going to bail you out
when you deposit money in the bankers
there's no deposit insurance right but
we're also not going to bail any banks
out when they get in trouble we're just
stepping back and letting the market be
free and look before 1913 the United
States had no Federal Reserve it had no
bank bailouts not had bank regulations
particularly in a state level which were
disasters but and generally the economy
grew the fastest in human history from
from the Civil War until to World War
one it was an amazing period of economic
growth and economic success without a
Fed without central planners that's what
I'd like to see what the lesson of 2008
is get rid of the Federal Reserve the
lesson of 2008 is stop regulating the
banks and the credit agencies and the
rating agencies and all these things
that
stort market so my bernie people are not
going to be happy with you because
you're both address you're both saying
there's a problem here you're saying the
problem is the government is
artificially controlled what Wall Street
can do he would say we have to control
them even more and I'm saying we've
tried Bernie's solution since the Great
Depression right during the Great
Depression the first thing FDR did when
he came into office in 33 and 34 it's
passed massive bodies of financial
regulations since then we've had
inflation we've had S&L crisis we've had
2008 those regulations that were passed
in 33 and 34 don't work they never
worked they were they were disasters
from the beginning it just takes decades
to see their full manifestation the
solution is not to load up on them a
whole new set of the same bad thing you
don't if you run an experiment it
doesn't work you don't double up on the
experiment right what you do is you
rethink your your your fundamental ideas
about it and we need to rethink finance
from the beginning yeah so I love that
this really all comes down to human
nature right because if you were let's
say you were of the Burney mindset you
say we have to regulate the more I guess
what he would say is or what you would
say is well someone even if with all the
regulations on earth someone because of
human nature is going to come in and
figure out a way to still screw it oh no
egg you lations that are screwing the
system up right the relations cause
right crisis the regulations provide
incentives for people to behave in
particular ways that are screwy I'm
saying is the reason we don't we trust
regulation and we don't trust markets
and this is the key right yeah because
in every field this is true a crisis
happens we regulate it which causes
another crisis to happen we regulate
even more which causes a bigger crisis
and this was observed by Iran in the 50s
and 40s this isn't a new phenomenon this
is the way government functions this is
the way human beings function is the
fundamental we don't trust is
self-interest we think that
self-interest leads to lying stealing
cheating all this bad behavior so we
regulate it right so all that happens is
the regulations cause incentives to be
misaligned and bad things to happen so
we all know it's greed its self-interest
again so we regulate even more I'm
saying that if we trust
self-interest if we got it and why do we
trust the regulator's why do we you walk
into an elevator anyway in the United
States and there's a little diploma on
the elevator thing says a government
regulated inspector this sale of it it
won't kill you yeah and why do we go oh
okay now it's safe because the elevator
inspector we believe is for the public
interest he's under common good he's not
self-interested god forbid be
self-interested right he's just doing if
all of us and I'm saying that's a bogus
even moral standard I don't want people
to be in the public interest the public
interest means nothing so you think
these elevator guys are just walking in
there and sign on that sheet I'm saying
that the guy who expects the elevator is
a government employee is probably much
more open to bribes then if the
inspection of the elevators was done by
the insurance company that if the
something bad happened to they elevated
they would suffer financial cost and
that guy would be fired the elevator
inspector hired by the government will
never be fired he's got tenure
I take food inspectors in California
California farmers are much more worried
about the grocery store inspectors than
they are about the the government
inspectors because the grocery store has
something to lose if they poison us
right the inspector from the government
has nothing to lose this is why when
when Ben Bernanke Ben Bernanke in my
view is one of the most awful Federal
Reserve Chairman ever he screwed up oh
eight he completely messed up oh seven
he the recoveries being the slowest in
history
everything the Fed did everything he
said in oh seven oh eight turned out to
be wrong he was wrong about everything
he said the housing crisis wouldn't
happen it wouldn't cause a recession
Freddie and Fannie were fine Lehman
Brothers wasn't gonna go back but I've
got a list of all his statements they're
all wrong what happened - he got rehired
right and today he gets a quarter of a
million dollars to give a speech right
you either become a hero
what happened to the private bankers who
actually drove their businesses who did
what the Fed did to their own businesses
they're out of jobs yeah they're not
buying jails I know Bundy would like
them all in jail but they've suffered
the consequences
they've lost their jobs nobody wants to
talk to them nobody will hire them again
that's what happens in business in
business if you fail you out government
when you fail you we reward you
particularly if you are in the
bureaucracy right so I'm saying let's
shift the model to where we we trust
individuals we trust their self-interest
we trust we leave
companies alone and if the companies do
bad things let them fail we can boycott
them if we don't like the way they
behave towards I don't know gays or
whatever if we don't like their behavior
don't don't go to chick-fil-a just don't
by chick-fil-a boycott them right so
this is where you would say if the if
the Christian pizza maker doesn't want
to make pizza for gays you wouldn't say
let the government stop them from doing
that you would say well boycott them and
don't give them business and yes but I
want to be a little bit more radical
than that because because this is a
problem we have Ted Cruz and people like
that talking about religious freedoms
what religious freedom I just believe in
freedom and the fact is that people have
a right to discriminate so I would
expand it if there are take of them your
business yeah don't get so so my point
says if the bacon doesn't want to give
doesn't want to bake a cake for Jewish
wedding he has just as much right to do
that as he has to discriminate but I
would never go near the plate I would I
would I would I would stand outside with
a placard I'd be on the barricades to
drive that Amal bastard out of business
right but but he has a right to be a
bigot people have a right to be racist
we don't have a weight to force it on
you yeah I'm with you on that you know
some of my friends on the left that will
say well but they're using you know the
public street that they're on so then
they they we wouldn't want them to
discriminate against black people and I
get the idea behind but once they walked
off the public street into your store
it's yours I
I am very discriminating and who I
invite to my home it's not
discrimination based on race so any of
these other factors but people who I
think are nice I invited people who
don't like are not invited we all
discriminate discrimination is a good
thing what we need to teach people is
not to discriminate based on stupid
things or non-essential things you
discriminate based on a person's
character that's the appropriate
discrimination but are they always going
to be irrational people are they always
going to be stupid people they're always
going to be bad people yes but we the
job of the government is not to
legislate them out of their stupidity
the job of the government is to let them
suffer the consequences of this
stupidity which means back off yeah we
pair it we barely got into this here so
I know I certainly hope you'll come back
so we can unpack more absolutely would
be happy to yeah this is a pleasure and
I think I'm looking forward to the
to the comment sections it's going to be
wildin all right I want to thank your
own Brooke for joining me today you guys
can follow him on Twitter it's at your
own Brooke and he does respond and he'll
fight with you and send your links and
maybe I'll send you some of these
pamphlets and you can check out his book
equal is unfair in the description right
down below thanks
you